hindsight's a funny thing isn't it every
season i do these pre-season videos
hyping up shows that i think my main
audience which is you would probably
enjoy
some are easy picks for those lists
while others i judge based on the
premise or what i know of the source
material now looking back at this season
though i realized that there's been some
really good stuff that i missed out on
when i went through the seasonal list at
first glance
so this is what this video is for now
that we have most of the season in the
books it's pretty interesting to go back
and look at the pre-season video to
compare the listed shows there have been
some big hits and some big misses for
sure so today we'll be going over what i
think
ended up being the season's top 10 anime
i won't be including remakes or sequels
though so you won't be seeing stuff like
shaman king in there but before we begin
i'd like to encourage you to give the
video a like
hit that subscribe button and turn on
your notifications so that you can be
first in the line next time i upload a
video
done okay right let's get on with the
list we start off with rom-com or
samarkey
[Music]
admittedly this show is something that i
overlooked a bit during the pre-season
however the voice actors got me
featuring some of my favorite names in
the industry who are ironically all
close friends who've worked together
immensely they've been through a lot
kind of like the characters in the
actual show with a title that outright
says the childhood friend won't lose
the show feels like some kind of
self-aware rom-com it ends up being some
sort of revenge story rom-com that i
don't think that we see that often the
premise is really good and i think that
the characters all have chemistry with
one another either because of the
writing or the execution since the
voices behind the characters have so
much chemistry already i really dig the
cutesy art style and the color palettes
in this one it's just perfect for a show
like this and i feel that it helped make
the show a lot more entertaining than it
seemed at first the show won't blow
anyone's minds but it's a decent pick up
for the season especially if you're one
who likes rom-coms
ninth on the list is combatants will be
dispatched
okay so listen to this you've got an
obnoxious protagonist who looks like
he's had enough of life on an adventure
besides the straight-laced blonde girl
he's with our protagonist is joined by
an ambitious captain of the god a dark
mage and a chimera with cenibio
tendencies
if it sounds like some sort of konosuba
love child you're absolutely correct as
it's from the same creator from an
anecdotal standpoint
it seems that when it comes to fantasy
the same court of archetypes and
personalities to form that specific four
or five person party has proven to work
excellently i mean you do see
shades of it in the core cast of ari
furetha princess connect has something
resembling it too they all differ in
execution and for combatants will be
dispatched that comes in the form of
some tactical warfare gimmicks and a
heavy focus on lewd comedy if you're up
for something like gonosuba and want
more of the laughs and the degeneracy
from it combatants should be part of
your watch list no question
at number eight we take a look at
shadows house
shadows house is an interesting show
before the season started i praised its
overall ambiance in its victorian era
backdrop i felt that we're due for
another creepy gothic anime and so far i
think that my expectations for shadow's
house have been met the mysteries are
great and i had my ample full of
suspense from this anime and while i
wouldn't put shadows house's anime of
the season candidate i think the
cloverworks has done an overall
excellent job in bringing the series to
life seriously it just does such a good
job at captivating the audience with
those eerie supernatural elements and
the overall cinematography
you get drawn into the mystery of the
shadow's house and like a spectre the
anime just doesn't let you go once it's
in your grass i can't wait to see more
with each passing episode and as more
questions appear
with everyone that gets answered if
you're like me and if you're looking for
something chilly and mysterious this
season
has this great anime for you
[Music]
seventh in line is don't toy with me
miss nagatoro
[Music]
it's a show that i braced myself for
early on in the season but surprisingly
the reception towards nagatoro has been
pretty tame i admit that seeing
nakathora's smug face with the first few
episodes was quite addictive and i think
that in terms of the production side of
things
the show is serviceable the acting's
great and i think that the art is just
right for a show like this
i can't help but feel sorry for the poor
guy though the show has been getting a
steady increase in his fan base through
the anime adaptation and i think that a
lot of it has to do with the characters
and their antics we've seen the bullying
turning into romance thing before
still i don't think that makes it a bad
show if you're looking for a rom-com
with that premise nagatoro should
suffice in giving you your fill for the
season
number six on the list is higahiro
here's another winner that i admittedly
overlooked before the season started i
mean i figured that the premise might
not be everyone's cup of tea but after
watching the first few eps and reading
some of the source material i'd say that
higahiro is one of the best romances
that we have this season i'd also say
that you should give the show a chance
because when you do
it does shine in a lot of ways it seems
the past few years the parent chart
dynamic in anime has been gaining some
momentum despite the premise possibly
setting off some red flags
i don't find anything too questionable
about the series yep there's some minor
fan service in there but come on
are we still piling about fan service in
anime in this day and age especially
when things like ero manga sensei exists
to make whatever fan service in higger
heroes seem like child's play to be
completely honest gigahero is a very
wholesome series filled with dramatic
moments
about relationships and taking
responsibilities gigahero reminds me of
those self-help shows like domozaki or
origairu and if you want something like
that but with a parental relationship
element higahiro is the show for you
next in line is eden zero
for all the memes and jokes made about
mashima's character design decisions and
such eden zero has proved to be a pretty
cool show that deserves to be one of the
top anime of the season it's still early
but it's providing ample entertainment
for me especially as a fan of fairy tale
i'd have the fairy tale comparisons to
end with that statement because i feel
the eden zero deserves to stand on its
own as a quirky fun adventure with how
hit or miss the studio has been the past
few years jc staff has done a pretty
good job
adapting the series i didn't notice some
index tier rushing or one punch man
two-tier animation i'd say the eden
zero's not exactly the most unique anime
out there but it doesn't need to be the
tropes are there the usual mushy my hero
things are there the shonen cliches are
there but
are they automatically bad i'd say no
especially if you can put them on a
light-hearted and easy-going adventure
like this one eden zero
knows what it is and it instead focuses
its efforts on giving the fans of the
genre
exactly what they want
from a personal perspective 86 is one of
my most anticipated shows before the
start of the season it felt like a
breath of fresh air for action like
novels casual watchers would probably be
hooked by mandatory waifu character lena
the edgy feel that the trailer exudes or
the mecca and military elements
it seemed to be a renaissance of the
mecca genre in the modern era does 86
manage to revive mecca into the
mainstream well not really however what
it does provide
is an excellent story that i feel
perfectly fits the current state of the
times i don't really want to go too
political but when looking at the
content of 86 it does have those
undertones hidden underneath the
gripping story of hardship and
perseverance it has a lot to do with the
status quo and the class differences
between citizens some racial conflict
and some surprisingly deep ideas about
military might and what at first glance
could look like a seasonal popcorn flick
that's not even mentioning
an amazing soundtrack presented by the
legendary hiroyuki sawano 86
is a winner for the season you should
definitely check it out
when the season started i honestly
didn't know what to expect from vv it
looked appealing enough and i wanted to
watch sci-fi and it's done by the guys
who gave
us re-zero but expectations were rather
tempered when i look back well it turns
out that what we have here is a strong
candidate for anime of the season just
like 86 before it i feel that vivi has a
baby of strong themes mostly to do with
morals politics and the fight against
fate however we all know casual watchers
typically
aren't immediately drawn to a series
through those themes right so for that
vb has its spectacular visuals
amazing soundtrack and a fast paced
execution of the story it's very
eye-catching to say the least even
having one of my favorite anime fights
that feature female characters and
there's more on that on the other video
that i'll be linking overall i'd say
that this anime is amazing
if you like sci-fi animators
action-packed and way more than just
your usual popcorn flick give vivi a
shot
i know you're gonna enjoy it number two
for our list is
to your eternity
now here's a show that was a no-brainer
for inclusion to the pre-season list it
seems that everyone's hyped for the show
and what do you know it didn't
disappoint one bit it's beautiful in so
many ways
first it's the art and the presentation
second is how immersive and gripping of
a journey
is from start to end it's one of those
shows that i like to call anime aspiring
to become art just like the
feature-length films and stuff like
violet evergarden so your eternity
succeeds in following the footsteps of
those anime invoking strong emotions and
giving us an intricate look at the human
experience feelings like joy
pain sadness and all the other things
that make humanity what it is
are well presented in this title and
it's a show that takes you along for the
roller coaster of emotions now i
wouldn't say the show is flawless by the
mere concept of my belief that there's
nothing perfect however it does come
very close to being one of those
cinematic anime that people will
eventually look back on with high regard
a unique premise done well in such a
beautiful way is a recipe for anime of
the season or even the year
candidate
however it somehow still doesn't make it
to the first place i feel that to your
eternity is super narrowly edged out by
my pick for this season
tokyo revengers
it raised stein's gate and re-zero fans
rejoice
you found your successor in the whole
time travel genre and it ended up being
just as great as those titles
context considered prior to the season i
had high hopes for tokyo revenges but i
placed the show here at number one
because the anime
just blew me away exceeding those
expectations by a mile with the time
travel stories i mentioned i think the
tokyo revenger sets itself apart with
how rough it seems in its atmosphere i
say that not in a bad way but you do
have to deal with the violence
the gangs and the high octane action
scenes the completely different and way
more action-packed atmosphere compared
to the mystery-leaning shows that i just
mentioned it's a gritty exciting action
series that just goes full throttle from
the get-go
thrilling action sequences along with
some heart-wrenching drama
make this my pick for anime of the
season now while i wouldn't call it an
underappreciated anime by any means
i do think that more people need to
check out this show
there we have it my top 10 picks for
spring 2021 do you agree with my picks
or not
share your thoughts in the comments
section if you ended up enjoying the
video and the recommendations you may
want to check out some perks that vinnie
tube offers i set some exclusive videos
for the channel that you can access
through channel memberships if you're up
for some specific titles such as re zero
or sword art online you can head over
and get some memberships for you and
your friends speaking of those titles
videos on those are also available on my
other channel vini tube kai
it's a channel that deals more with
video essays and analysis videos so if
you fancy that sort of content head on
over there through the link that i'll be
dropping that's it for today
hope you had fun until next time